die natureisbahn im schweizer
wintersportort davos mit 18.000
quadratmetern die größte präparierte
natureisbahn europas auf den umgerechnet
rund zweieinhalb fußballfeldern
trainieren profis und solche die es
vielleicht einmal werden möchten
der gebürtige davoser handy war früher
eishockey spieler erst mit 30 jahren
entdeckte er den eisschnelllauf seit 15
jahren trainierte jeden winter auf der
außenbahn
sie gilt als eine der schnellsten der
welt es ist eine schnell durch den
vielen wer die sonne auf dem eis bilden
würde und dann ist gibt es hier ein
kleiner wasser filmen und wer macht
eigentlich das eis sehr schnell
und wenn die temperatur stimmt wie heute
wenn die sonneneinstrahlung kommt wenn
man die richtigen zeitpunkt richtig dass
sich eis wie also ich würde sagen wie in
eine totale die anlage ist fast 140
jahre alt dass sie über die
landesgrenzen hinweg bekannt wurde ist
den britischen schlittschuh verband zu
verdanken der hier seine eisläufer
trainierte in der brust fanden mehr als
30 europa und weltmeisterschaften im
eisschnelllauf und eiskunstlauf statt im
sommer eine bahn für leichtathleten im
winter eine eisbahn
sie ist wegen des unbeständigen klimas
nur noch und zweieinhalb monate pro
saison geöffnet
früher waren es vier profi sportler
trainieren längst woanders
sie laufen die eishallen lieber weise da
jede stunde die gleichen verhältnisse
haben weil sie die sicherheit nicht
haben
die gelassenheit es funktioniert hat
dieses jahr nicht erwartet ich halt bis
nächstes jahr also das geht halt im
profisport nicht das geht nur wenn man
ja wenn man es einfach macht alles liebt
doch die tradition geht weiter jeden
morgen und abend präparieren die
eismacher die fläche sie wird vom schnee
geräumt
und ein lage um lage mit wasser aus den
schweizer alpen bespritzt das
anschließend gefriert die kunst
schnelles und gutes eis zu machen haben
die davoser seit 1877 generation für
generation weitergegeben
das ist einfach die langjährige
erfahrung die dahinter steckt das ist
die situative entscheidung wie was macht
man bei welchen temperaturen wann
spricht man genau wann spricht man nicht
man lässt man das alles ruhen auf der
sportanlage finden auch kurse statt
anna barbara k fliesst lehrt
eiskunstlauf sie trainiert ihre
schülerinnen zweimal pro woche und zeigt
ihnen auch wie eine pirouette korrekt
ausgeführt hat
das laufen ist eine wunderschöne
verbindung zwischen kunst und athletik
und man kann sich selber ausdrücken man
hat die springen hat die pirouetten und
man kann zur musik laufen es gibt
tausend ausdrucksmöglichkeiten und ich
denke das ist das was den sport so
faszinierend macht
und die jungen talente wissen genau was
ich machen möchte
15.000 hobby eisläufer kommen zwischen
mitte dezember und ende februar hierher
wintersport gäste fahren gratis
der eissport für einheimische wie
claudio menge seit vielen jahren ein
wichtiges geschäft der gelernte
messerschmied ist präsident des
internationalen schlittschuh clubs davos
und mit seinem familienunternehmen hatte
sich darauf spezialisiert schlittschuhe
den richtigen schliff zu geben was macht
der kunde mit diesen schlicht schulen
gilt einfach nochmal eislaufen oder eben
ist mit wettkämpfen tätig beispielsweise
und anhand dessen können wir wirklich
den schläfen sprechen anpassen
bis ende februar geht die saison auf der
natureisbahn wer dann noch wintersport
in davos machen möchte muss auf sie
hatten steigen